[music] these days you are fighting for our people in the donbas for the security of our homeland russia russia has always stood for the creation of a system of equal and indivisible security a system that is vital for the entire world community in December last year we proposed to conclude a security guarantee treaty russia called on the west to honest dialogue to the search for reasonable compromise solutions, taking into account each other's interests, all in vain, the NATO country did not want to hear us, which means that in fact they had completely different plans and we saw it openly, preparations were underway for another punitive operation in the Donbass, an invasion of our historical lands, including Crimea, in Kyiv, they announced the possible acquisition of nuclear weapons, the NATO bloc began actively and the military development of the territory adjacent to us, thus systematically creating an absolutely unacceptable threat to us, and directly at our borders, Russia gave a preemptive rebuff to Greece, this was forced
a
timely and only right
decision the
decision of a sovereign strong
independent country the united states of
america, especially after the collapse of the
soviet union, started talking about their
exclusivity
, thereby humiliating not only the whole world but also
their satellites who have
to pretend that they don’t notice anything and
dutifully swallow it all, but we
another country russia has a different character
we will never give up love for the
motherland from faith and traditional values
from the customs of the ancestors from respect for all
peoples and cultures and in the west these
millennial values ​​apparently
decided to cancel such moral
degradation became the basis of the cynical
falsification of the history of the second world  we
honor all the soldiers of the allied armies of the
Americans, the British and the French, the
participants in the resistance, the
brave soldiers and partisans of China, all
those who defeated Nazism and militarism,
dear comrades, today the militia of
Donbass, together with the fighters of the Russian army, are
fighting on their own land, you are fighting
for  motherland for its future so that
no one forgets the lessons of World War II
so that there is no place in the world for
executioners and Nazis the death of each of our
soldiers and officers
is grief for all of us and an
irreparable loss for relatives and
friends of the
state regions enterprises
public organizations will do everything
to surround  care for such families to
help them special support
we will provide the children of the dead and wounded
comrades-in-arms a presidential decree was
signed today
we remember how the enemies of russia tried to
use gangs of international terrorists against us they
tried to
sow national and religious
enmity in order to weaken us from within split
us nothing happened
today our fighters of different
nationalities together in battle
cover each other with bullets and shrapnel
like siblings, and in this is the strength of Russia, the
great invincible strength of our united
multinational people
today you are defending what the
fathers and grandfathers of the great-grandfathers fought
for, for them, the highest meaning of life has always been
well-being and  homeland security
[music]
a
[applause]
[music]